[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el Parlamento Europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos que está ocurriendo
con las cadenas de suministro está
viendo una crisis estamos teniendo una
tormenta perfecta antes de Navidad antes
de pasar el debate con nuestros
invitados analizamos las causas de esta
crisis
teléfonos celulares ordenadores
automóviles electrodomésticos incluso
juguetes estos son algunos de los
productos que sufren la escasez de
materias primas a nivel mundial la
paralización que vivió el mundo en marzo
2020 por la pandemia trajo y la demanda
poco usual de algunos productos entre
ellos los insumos para los hogares por
ejemplo muebles pero también
computadoras necesarias para el trabajo
muy común por estos días pero además de
más demanda qué oferta también está el
hecho que hay escasez de semiconductores
básicos para todo tipo de productos
electrónicos un problema que proviene de
la falta de transportistas y de la
dependencia de China para fabricar los
también el aumento de los precios del
petróleo del gas y de la electricidad
afectan algunas empresas que tardan más
en producir productos las paralizaciones
puntuales que se producen en algunos
países asiáticos a causa del COBIT o de
fenómenos meteorológicos adversos han
provocado la tormenta perfecta en el
mundo
por todo ello podemos hablar de que el
comercio vive un atasco global en que
los barcos tardan a menudo semana sin
descargar y han sucedido
embotellamientos en los puertos sin que
los productos lleguen a las tiendas
ahora las dudas se centran en si el
mundo podrá hacer frente al periodo de
más consumo del año el de la Navidad y
en el debate de hoy para analizar todas
estas causas tenemos al eurodiputado
José Ramón Bauzá del grupo renovar
Europa y al periodista económico del
periódico El País Manuel Gómez Manuel
José Ramón muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros me gustaría empezar primero
de todo con José Ramón me gustaría
preguntarte la pandemia ahora la demanda
ha subido con un aumento del gasto en
los hogares pero parece que el comercio
no está siguiendo el mismo ritmo sobre
todo el también el transporte marítimo
está dando señales la globalización que
quizás estar tan interconectados es un
problema lo que pasa es que hay que
analizar muy bien la realidad de los
hechos durante la pandemia aunque
nosotros estuviéramos en nuestra casa la
gente seguía consumiendo y de hecho
había un consumo por internet mucho más
elevado como consecuencia no no podré
salir de nuestros domicilios
paralelamente a que el comercio se
producía y se mantenía y se incrementaba
en online lo que se estaba produciendo
es el cierre de empresas en cierre de la
industria como consecuencia precisamente
de ese acta donde se cierre absoluto por
lo tanto no se podía producir ahora que
se ha producido se ha producido la
normalización se ha podido empezar a
mover han empezado las empresas a
trabajar pero donde había una demanda
importante lo que hay es la no
existencia de muchos productos y
aquellos que sí que existen tienen mucho
retraso en su fabricación en su cadena
de producción y además hay que
incrementarse en este caso a que muchos
productos como consecuencia de que hay
un colapso en el tema del transporte no
llegan lo suficientemente rápido o en el
ritmo habitual a las empresas y a ello
también tenemos que montar Lego que
sumarle el hecho de que se produce un
colapso y un embudo en muchos puertos el
80% del transporte mundial se produce en
el ámbito marítimo y una de las grandes
dependencias en el ámbito del transporte
mundial viene mayoritariamente de Asia y
en concreto de China por lo tanto
déficit de productos tardar en arrancar
como consecuencia del cierre de muchas
empresas la demanda se ha producido se
va incrementar exponencialmente dentro
de unas semanas como consecuencia la
campaña de Navidad productos o en este
caso algunos componentes básicamente los
semiconductores y demás que son
necesario para fabricar también algunas
de los sistemas logísticos de transporte
como es el caso de automóviles y más
pues tampoco se producen en este momento
con lo cual es esa no una tormenta
perfecta como consecuencia de la
globalización pero si como consecuencia
de una pandemia que ha paralizado un
sector productivo y logístico pero ha
incrementado un sector de ventas que se
ha producido online en internet y que
ahora en esta fecha se va incrementar
exponencialmente
hay varios factores esta de esta
tormenta perfecta que explican
su pero sí que podríamos decir esta
pequeña crisis los países quizá pensaron
que parar la economía y luego volver
sería más fácil
pues se lo cierto es que de alguna
manera a sorprender sorprendido aunque
es cierto que hice ya se veía desde que
se empezaron a decretar los
confinamientos que no iba a ser fácil
porque las cadenas de suministro
especialmente la industria se colapsan
colapsaron rompieron y ahora que se está
viendo como comentaba José Ramón que el
incremento de la demanda tanto en el
consumo final como en el consumo
intermedio en las lo que es el sector
manufacturero está provocando mucha
presión sobre todas esas cadenas de
suministro se está viendo sobre todo con
los semiconductores en el sector del
automóvil por ejemplo Renault anunciado
que va a rebajar en 500.000 su
producción no recuerdo ahora si es
durante todo este año 500.000 vehículos
no recuerdes a las 6 durante todo el año
o durante la segunda mitad de este año
eso ha provocado como digo un colapso en
cadenas de suministro una pensión muy
grande sobre ella y al mismo tiempo
también está provocando centro de los
fabricantes de
dando un fenómeno de
acumulación de pedidos para evitar que
dentro de unos meses
verse con ese problema de suministro en
sus procesos de fabricación sos una cosa
que se llama efecto látigo y que además
agrava el problema dentro de las cadenas
de suministro y de la especialmente en
el sector manufacturero
también importantes o sumamente
importantes a tener en cuenta que
debemos focalizar el punto neurálgico de
todo ese proceso y de ese colapso está
produciendo en Asia y es importante
también tener en cuenta que todo eso
repercute en todo el mundo pero en este
caso es lo que nosotros nos afecta a
Europa como importa también pues porque
se produce un incremento de precio de
pongo un ejemplo para que seamos más
sencillo los filetes han incrementado de
tal forma que lo que antes valía uno
Aloha vale 10 un contenedor que antes
valía traer los 1500 € a Europa ahora
vale 15000 € el mismo producto en el
mismo contenedor pero x tiempo más tarde
con lo cual se está multiplicando por lo
menos por 10 el coste del mismo producto
puesto en este caso procedente de Asia
puesto aquí en Europa y un punto también
importante que no podemos pasar por alto
porque además es el día de nuestra
realidad faltan estamos en el transporte
marítimo que le he comentado para que
llegue el contenedor pero ese contenedor
llega uno determinados puertos pasa a
ser repartido logísticamente y ese
reparto se produce mediante en este caso
el transporte rodado en el transporte
rodado se producen también dos
características dos consecuencias como
vamos abriendo ramas de un árbol se
produce un déficit de conductores de
conductores no semiconductores y no de
personas físicas drivers los personas
que conducen y se produce un incremento
en el transporte como consecuencia del
incremento del precio del combustible
que estamos viendo ahora también en este
momento por lo tanto a ese colapso y ese
precio incrementado de los fletes donde
además hay una mayor demanda y faltan
productos se le produce leche cuando
llegue a Europa y en un puerto español
cómo puede ser el puerto de Algeciras en
los más importantes del mundo y Europa
por este caso el reparto en la cadena
logística se produce un sobre incremento
en costillas y me dejas añadir y eso se
produce con dos elementos por ejemplo en
torno al 80 el 90% del comercio mundial
va pues las fuerte marítimo y luego
sobre el comercio y también se
especialmente sobre el minorista
se está produciendo una gran expansión
del comercio electrónico que presiona
sobre la logística tanto el transporte
especialmente el transporte por
carretera y el transporte de última
milla lo cual hace que ese sector en
concreto de logística también tenga
presión a la hora de encontrar mano de
obra
tener en mente la deslocalización y
relocalizar la industria se puede hacer
esto en un mundo tan globalizado es
posible por supuesto es que esto al
final es una cuestión de oferta y
demanda de puesta del precio de puesta
un producto en la mesa del consumidor
final porque se había producido la
deslocalización hasta ahora pues como
consecuencia de que la mano de obra más
barata en la materia prima era mucho más
económica y era mucho más fácil y
económico para el productor el hacer una
preproduccion una producción intermedia
o una facturación interna en un país
asiático para luego traerlo aquí que es
lo que ocurre ahí es el lo que debemos
ahora pensar en Europa es decir
realmente ahora antes era más barato
pero ahora vale la pena irse a China a
fabricar si nos está costando mucho más
caro el traerlo ese ese no es
globalización realmente le podemos poner
el nombre o apellido que queramos es la
realidad de los hechos la economía se
mueve igual que la sociedad se mueve
igual que la vida se hoy hoy en día es
mucho más rentable y mucho más económico
producir en España producir en Europa
porque los costes y los fletes y el
tiempo en recibir esa materia prima es
mucho más elevado en coste y mucho menos
helado en tiempo que ocurre como estamos
desde localizados porque se ha decidido
producir fuera no tenemos capacidad
productiva y no tenemos infraestructura
industrial y productiva para que eso se
produzca con lo cual hay que repensar el
modelo qué es lo bueno de esto que la
iniciativa privada la industria es mucho
más rápida que la decisiones políticas
gracias a Dios no y al final debemos
estar siempre muy cerca yo siempre digo
de no ser un obstáculo para la industria
para la economía y simplemente dejarles
que ellos funcionen creo que sin duda
hoy en día y hablado pues con muchísimos
digamos actores o protagonismo o
protagonistas del sector privado en el
mismo si hoy pudiera empezar a producir
producir aquí ya lo harían repito por
tener costos más económicos por lo que
supone traerlo y por tener una mayor
rapidez en producción por lo que pone
traer también en container o sí y demás
lo que hoy está en Asia pero en todo
caso no hay que olvidar una cosa en este
momento concreto y en esta coyuntura
hablar de reindustrialización para
responder al problema actual
francamente no llega hay un problema o
sea la inversión que hace falta no se va
a dar mañana ni la construcción de esas
infraestructuras eso es uno de los
problemas y luego hay cosas que hemos
visto durante la pandemia que pueden
servir de ejemplo está bien que hablemos
de reindustrialización pero qué pasó con
las mascarillas que pasó con las
mascarillas no había mascarillas hubo
empresarios hubo iniciativas privadas
que dieron el paso de producir
ahora cuando ya en este mercado concreto
que es el mercado sanitario parece que
las cosas han vuelto a cierta normalidad
evidentemente con un incremento de
costes la producción europea sigue sin
ser competitiva con frente a la
producción asiática China el otro día
estábamos hablando por ejemplo en el
periódico en el país de unas empresas en
Francia que se lanzaron a invertir para
producir mascarillas y ahora no tienen
pedido porque no son competitivas porque
hay una gran diferencia de coste
incluso con ese
totalmente de acuerdo con lo que dice
rápidamente estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con lo que dice Manuel es efectivamente
la producción sería media ten un poco
tiempo no soy una industrialización como
tal no pero hay que invertir en la
logística y las infraestructuras que es
lo que ha hecho la administración Baden
hace unos días ha invertido un billón de
euros precisamente en infraestructura
logística eso es lo que a lo mejor
deberíamos a lo mejor no deberíamos
hacer aquí invert estructura
precisamente para reducir costes para
decir tiempo y estar preparados
en función de la oferta demanda y las
necesidades pero ya nos ahorraríamos en
este caso por parte de la administración
pública la inversión que ahora mismo
falta y requiere en Europa
ha sido tú
las cosas
les esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy gracias por ver France 24 en
español